Das sieht gut aus, scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich bin ein bisschen später, das hat nur sekundär was mit der Zeitumstellung zu tun.
Ich habe hier ein neues Handy, ich fange am dritten, vierten bei einem neuen Arbeitgeber an.
Ich habe hier aktuell ein Handy von einer Firma, wo ich jetzt arbeite, das muss ich aber abgeben, aber ich habe jetzt die Rufnummer mitgenommen.
Ich habe die Rufnummer umziehen lassen und habe mir ein neues Handy gekauft und eben ist mir eingefallen, du hast ja deine Banking-App noch nicht umgezogen.
Also habe ich die 1822-App runtergeladen und da hat die mir erst mal angezeigt, ich soll irgendeine QR-Code, frag mich nicht, eingeben, hatte ich natürlich nicht.
War auf noch einem älteren Handy drauf, ich überweise mit dem Ding eigentlich so gut wie nie was.
So, was machst du jetzt? Bisschen drin rumgeklickt, auf einmal konnte ich mich gar nicht mehr einmelden, bin ich an den Rechner, habe ich mich angemeldet und glücklicherweise haben sie sich selbst gebadet.
Normalerweise braucht man da auch eine TAN aus der App, um sich einzuloggen, aber glücklicherweise haben sie sich selbst gebadet.
Sie haben ein neues TAN-Verfahren eingeführt, was man jetzt quasi einfach nur noch per Klick und ohne zu scannen benutzen kann.
Und deswegen haben sie das TAN-Verfahren gesettet und man konnte ganz normal noch mal übers Telefon das Online-Banking aktivieren.
Und das habe ich dann gemacht und habe jetzt die App runtergeladen für das neue. Alter, das ist unnötig kompliziert gemacht.
Ich frage mich, was ist, wenn man, wenn man wie ich jetzt halt das alte Handy verloren hat, geklaut bekommen hat oder sonst was.
Also ich meine, ich habe das abgegeben und nicht daran gedacht, die App zu damals irgendwie umzustellen.
Dann braucht man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Fax oder so.
Da muss man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Fax hinschicken und man kriegt in einmal Code oder sowas.
Alles ultra-Pains-Champ-ig gemacht, sage ich euch.
Extremely Pains-Champ.
Ich muss gerade mal hier die Banking-Sachen wegmachen.
So, exzellent.
Ich schäme auf den Haufen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Also keine Ahnung, warum das so kompliziert sein muss wieder.
Aber gut, ich verstehe es in gewisser Weise schon, dass man für einen Login und so nochmal eine gültige TAN brauchen.
Das könnte sich ja jeder, der dann online Passwort irgendwoher hat, könnte sich ja einloggen.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht so ein Zweck der Sache.
Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen, seit ich Apple Pay verwende, ist meine Bargeld-Benutzung und die Sparkassenkarte oder generell die Bankkarten-Benutzung ist schon ganz schön zurückgegangen.
Also es ist wirklich ganz nice.
Ich hätte das normalerweise wahrscheinlich nie gemacht.
Weil ich habe nicht gedacht, dass es irgendwie taugt, dass es nice ist.
Vor allem wollte ich nicht, dass Apple da noch mehr damit zu tun haben soll, als es eh schon zu tun hat.
Und le chuck, danke schön für den Sub.
Zumindest irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, ok, als ich mal beim Lidl gewesen bin, habe ich mir gedacht, hey, die haben doch diese komische Lidl-App, mit der kann man doch auch bezahlen.
Ist doch besser, als sie jedes Mal an der Kasse rumzustehen und rumzufuddeln.
An das Geld rauszusuchen.
Also hatte ich die Lidl-App installiert und dann habe ich das mal mit Lidl Pay ausprobiert.
Und Lidl Pay ist halt schon mal besser als Bargeld, aber immer noch doof, weil man die App entsperren muss und dann in so einen komischen Scanner halten muss mit dem QR-Code und sowas.
Ist ja alles nicht so geil.
Also habe ich mir überlegt, wenn du jetzt schon mal Lidl Pay ausprobiert hast, dann nimmst du einfach jetzt auch mal Apple Pay.
Oder halt das, man kann auch Google Pay nehmen, halt das, was im Smartphone native integrated ist.
Und da habe ich das eingerichtet mit meiner Kreditkarte und easy.
Jetzt gehe ich sogar schon zur Ice Dealer und wenn die Ice Dealer irgendeine Kartenzahlungsmöglichkeit hat, zahle ich bei der Ice Dealer auch mit Apple Pay.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Klick, klick, dranhalten, BIP geht.
Einzige, wo es nicht funktioniert hat bisher, die ein Kartenlesegerät hatten, ist das Amt.
Wo ich, ich musste zum Amt, um ein polizeiliches Führungszeugnis zu beantragen.
Und da musste man, ich weiß nicht, was es war, 10 Euro oder so oder 20 Euro, irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, 8 Euro, ich keine Ahnung genau.
Man musste, man musste ein bisschen, ein bisschen Gebühren bezahlen.
Ist ja logisch.
Ich meine, wir bezahlen Steuern erst, fuck, aber das ist natürlich nicht umsonst, logischerweise.
Ich meine, wozu bezahle ich zehntausende Euro an Steuern, wenn natürlich dann ab und zu, wenn ich mal was will, das ist selbstverständlich, muss das natürlich Geld kosten.
Ist ja klar.
Naja, zumindest habe ich das, habe ich das beantragt und da sollte ich, da konnte ich auch Kartenzahlungen machen.
Habe ich probiert mit Apple Pay, aber das Amt war nicht in der Lage, Apple Pay kontaktloses NFC bezahlen zu processen.
Das ging nicht.
Da musste ich an diesen komischen Automaten.
Also sonst hat es überall funktioniert, plus im Amt nicht.
Ja gut, es gibt noch mehr Sachen, die Arbeitsplätze abschafft.
Müssen sie sich halt was anderes überlegen.
Ist halt so, ist in der IT auch so.
Wenn du da nicht am Ball bleibst, kannst du halt bald nichts mehr gescheit, das was gebraucht wird.
Ist halt heute so.
Willst du machen?
Kannst nicht einfach immer darauf hoffen, dass alles so bleibt, wie es vor 100 Jahren, vor 50 Jahren oder gar vor, jetzt teilweise vor 10 Jahren noch gewesen ist.
Es ändert sich halt.
Und es ist egal, ob das Arbeitsplätze abschafft oder nicht oder wie auch immer.
Es wird eh gemacht, weil es ist bequem.
Und das einfachste, was du machen kannst, wenn du eine, mal angenommen du willst irgendeine App raushauen oder irgendeinen Service raushauen,
aber es gibt da schon eins, zwei Leute, die quasi auch so einen Service machen.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist, das muss einfacher sein.
Billiger geht auch, aber es muss einfacher sein.
Und sobald das einfacher ist, machen das die Leute.
Eventuell sogar, wenn es ein bisschen teurer ist.
Guckt euch das mal an.
WhatsApp.
WhatsApp ist das beste Beispiel für.
WhatsApp hat sich rasant, also wirklich mega.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Statistiken gibt.
Also WhatsApp hat sich rasant durchgesetzt.
Und WhatsApp war bei weitem nicht der erste Messenger-Dienst, den es auf dem Smartphone gegeben hat.
Ich meine, es hat alles angefangen, mal vor einer Weile, vor einer ganzen Weile mit
OL-Messenger, Yahoo-Messenger, MSN-Messenger, ICQ, Skype gab es eine Weile.
Und vieles davon, gerade Skype und sowas, das gab es auch alles.
Das gab es auch alles auf dem Smartphone.
Und manche Leute haben das auch benutzt und fanden das auch ganz nice.
Aber warum hat sich WhatsApp durchgesetzt?
Genau, erstens, weil die Kacknoobs es nicht gecheckt haben.
Aber wie kommen die Kacknoobs überhaupt zu dieser Annahme, dass man mit WhatsApp kostenlos SMS verschicken kann?
Das liegt daran, weil sie das einzig Sinnvolle gemacht haben.
Sie haben gesagt, wir scheißen auf Datenschutz und wir scheißen auf irgendwie Money und sonst was.
Es hat am Anfang sogar was gekostet.
Sondern wir benutzen die Handynummer der Leute anstatt noch eine zusätzliche Nummer.
Und das war halt ein Riesending, weil die Handynummer ist eUnique pro User.
Da brauchst du ja eine Handynummer für dich.
Also die hat eh jeder eine eindeutige Nummer.
Und weil WhatsApp die Handynummer genommen hat, hat es keine zusätzliche Nummer mehr gebraucht.
Und die Leute kamen dann so auf eine doofe Idee.
Oh, damit kann man ja kostenlos SMS verschicken.
Es ist halt keine SMS, aber das haben die Leute halt nicht gecheckt.
Die Leute haben gesehen, ich installiere App.
Ich habe meine Telefonnummer und mit der Telefonnummer kann ich jetzt Nachrichten verschicken.
Und das kommt dann bei den anderen an.
So, und deswegen, das hat sich rasend durchgesetzt.
Warum? Weil sie es einfacher gemacht haben.
Keine extra Nummer, kein zusätzlicher Scheiß.
Einfach nur draufklicken.
Scheiß auf Datenschutz, alles sharen.
Inklusive Telefonbuch natürlich.
Aber die Leute, wenn die die Auswahl haben.
Seriously, was meint ihr, Chat? Was meint ihr?
Wenn so der 0815 die Auswahl hat zwischen Bequemlichkeit versus Datenschutz.
Was macht der?
Was macht der 0815 Pepega am Handy?
Hat er Probleme damit, seine Telefonnummer zu sharen und sein Telefonbuch zu sharen?
Was macht er?
Dem ist doch scheiß egal.
Der klickt auf alles except, weil er das eh gewohnt ist.
Und es ist bequem.
Und er freut sich danach noch, dass er jetzt quasi 60 Telefonnummern geshared hat.
Von Leuten, die das vielleicht gar nicht wollen.
Was ja auch ein bisschen problematisch ist, ehrlich gesagt, bei WhatsApp, aber okay.
Ich glaube, da gibt es mittlerweile sogar eine Option für, dass man das nicht mehr machen muss, oder?
Wobei ich glaube, in den WhatsApp-Bedingungen steht wahrscheinlich drin,
dass man, also ich rate das jetzt mal, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist,
wahrscheinlich steht in den WhatsApp-Bedingungen drin,
dass man nur Nummern sharen darf, deren Erlaubnis man hat.
Und du bestätigst, dass du die Erlaubnis eingeholt hast oder so ein Shit.
Sodass WhatsApp schön raus ist quasi.
Hat natürlich niemand gemacht.
Und dann ist gut.
Deswegen hat sich das einfach rasant durchgesetzt, weil es easy as fuck gewesen ist.
Und danach kamen die anderen auch auf den Trichter von Telegram und Signal und sonstige Geschichten.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist total, aber das interessiert die Leute auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist, aber das interessiert die Leute nicht.
Es muss möglichst easy und einfach sein.
Jaylee, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich zeige euch mal was, bevor der Stream so richtig anläuft.
Hallo?
Ich wollte eigentlich meine V-M starten.
Ich habe gestern noch kurz ein bisschen am V-M-Champ rumgebaut.
Was ist das für Bettge-Musik?
Extrem Bettge-Musik.
Bettge-Time.
Dabei sind wir gerade aufgestanden.
Moment, Moment, wir brauchen eine Morning-Music.
Habe ich doch auch hier irgendwo.
Kommt besser.
Ja, okay.
Das, das, das, das, das geht, das geht besser.
Ja, das habe ich gemacht.
Kann ich löschen.
Hier unten hängt das Kommando aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Ich weiß nicht so genau warum.
Hä?
Was genau hängt hier unten?
Irgendwas.
Docker-PS hängt.
Warum auch immer.
Easy.
Ich mache jetzt einfach das ganze Terminal zu.
Lul.
Dead.
Docker-Restart.
So, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Ich habe nämlich gestern noch weiter gemacht.
Ja, das brauchen wir jetzt alles nicht.
So.
Was?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es von mir will, aber okay.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es ja auch gar nicht mehr.
So, okay.
Nice.
So.
Und jetzt bilden wir das mal.
Bild.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas ist egal.
So.
Okay, ich lasse es mal kurz bilden und dann zeige ich euch das allerwichtigste Feature,
was ich gestern noch eingebaut habe.
Moin.
Ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, ist noch irgendwas Spannendes gewesen.
Wir gucken uns mal eine Runde GitHub Trends an.
So wie immer.
Und um festzustellen, dass es wieder genau der gleiche Shit ist wie gestern.
Ja.
Das ist wieder genau der gleiche Shit ist wie letzte Woche.
Ein bisschen Krypto Zeug und der Rest AI AI AI AI.
Ohne Pause.
So AI.
Das war klar.
AI.
Nee.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was Alpaca Laura sein soll.
Das klingt auch nach AI.
Lama, das klingt so nach AI.
Ja, natürlich.
AI.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Okay, irgendwas von Microsoft.
Integrating, Cutting, Edged, LLM.
Ach doch, Machine Learning.
Das ist auch.
Das ist auch AI.
AI.
Comfy UI.
Ah, AI.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Es heißt UI.
Warum auch immer.
AI.
Alter, es ist jetzt ja mal gut, man.
Was ist mit den Trends los, Alter?
Wir haben eine Zeit für Neues.
So, High Performance.
Okay, es ist.
Es ist tatsächlich was.
Eigentlich AI.
AI.
Pai Shu.
Chat-GPT.
AI.
Wahrscheinlich AI.
Keine Ahnung.
Nee, Moment, Teamworks.
Das ist irgendwas animatizierend.
AI.
Alter, Leute.
Leute, ohne Scheiß.
Zwei Projekte sind nicht AI.
Der VM-Champ, der muss AI-Integration haben, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, der kann wahrscheinlich wieder die Hälfte nicht.
Deswegen benutzt ihn keiner.
Oder?
Ja, mit C-Modulen funktioniert es doch dann wieder nicht zusammen.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich das Ding.
Ja.
Funktioniert wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich funktioniert es bei vielen Sachen nicht.
Aber warum nicht?
Kann dann übel.
Mal safen.
Was ist das?
Moon Ray.
Teamworks Open Source Award-Winning-State-of-the-Art-Production-M.C-Module.
Das ist das.
Teamworks Open Source Award-Winning-State-of-the-Art-Production-M.C.R.T.-Renderer.
Ich weiß nicht, was ein M.C.R.T.-Renderer ist, aber irgendwelches Animationsstellzeug.
Alles klar.
Also die Hälfte war wieder AI, AI, AI.
Gucken wir mal, ob das...
Okay, alles gut.
So, ich habe das aller, aller wichtigste Feature eingebaut, gestern noch in dem VM-Champ.
Guck mal.
Man kann das Ding jetzt aufrufen.
Es wird nicht den Help angezeigt.
Man kann das Ding jetzt aufrufen mit...
KegW.
Oder gibst den ASCII KegW.
Aller, aller wichtigstes Feature.
Guck, so muss das sein.
Ah, ich habe überhaupt nicht mehr gemapped.
Ich sehe gerade, ich habe nicht mehr gemapped.
Schrift, Schrift größer und kleiner machen im Terminal.
Wie viele Stunden hast du für die Implementierung gebraucht?
Easy, fünf Minuten.
Ich habe das, ich habe das, ich habe, ich habe beschissen.
Passt mal auf.
Ich habe gecheatet.
Ich zeige es euch.
Wo bloß?
VM-Champ.
Ich habe, ich habe gecheatet.
Wobei, ich bin im Repo drin.
Ich könnte es euch einfach hier zeigen.
Egal, ich zeige es euch.
KegW-Command.
Das ist alles.
Das Bild ist einfach embedded.
Als Shell-Escape-Codes.
Einfach riesen, riesenlanger, mehrzeiliger String.
Das ist das Bild.
Ihr erkennt es vielleicht nicht.
Jetzt so auf den ersten Blick.
Aber es ist das Bild.
Und es macht nichts anderes als das Bild ausgeben.
Obvios.
Vielleicht, wenn man es schnell bewegt, erkennt man es dann vielleicht.
Und erkennt man es dann?
Ah, nee, geht nicht.
Nee, nee, nicht wirklich, ne?
Also das ist, das ist das Bild.
Was er hiermit, was er hiermit ausgibt.
Deswegen ist es auch schnell.
Das ist so schnell.
Wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal checken, wie schnell das ist?
Passt mal auf.
Wir testen jetzt, wie viel KegW pro Sekunde wir hinkriegen.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Weil, true.
Do.
Dann.
Okay, ganz viele KegW.
Und jetzt.
PV.
Nach.
Def Null.
Okay, Leute.
KegW pro Sekunde.
Wie viele KegWs pro Sekunde?
Ah, das ist aber schwach.
Das ist aber schwach.
Das ist aber nicht, das ist aber nicht viel.
Guck mal.
Wir schaffen nur 2,2 MB KegW pro Sekunde.
Das ist aber schwach.
Also da hätte ich gedacht, da geht ein bisschen mehr.
Aber das liegt auch daran, weil er jedes Mal das Ganze neu aufrufen muss.
Also ich bräuchte eigentlich noch einen Flag.
Print unendlich in der Endlosschleife KegW.
Das würde deutlich schneller gehen, als jedes Mal das Programm aufrufen.
Also das, das muss man sagen, das enttäuscht mich.
Das, das weiß ich gar nicht mehr Deutsch reden.
Das enttäuscht mich, dass wir nur 2,3 MB KegW pro Sekunde packen.
Das ist schon nicht gut.
Das ist nicht gut.
Aber wenn ich PV wegmache, werdet ihr sehen, es ist immer noch ganz schön viel.
2,5 MB KegW die Sekunde.
Seht ihr das?
Hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Sieht ja so aus, als würde er lachen.
Guck mal.
Dabei ist, dabei printet er einfach nur möglichst schnell auf die Konsole.
So, die wichtigsten Sachen haben wir schon mal.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist gecheatet, weil ich habe das Bild ja vorrendert.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Nee, weil ich kann das nicht in Twitch Chat posten.
Wenn ich in Twitch Chat poste, das ist ja Escape Sequenzen.
Das passiert nichts.
Ja, also ich habe gecheatet.
Ich habe das mit einem Renderer für die Command Line.
Habe ich das rausgehauen?
Ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dafür benutzt habe.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
2,5 MB CACW die Sekunde.
Das sollte neue Einheit werden.
Ich meine, es gibt schon viele Kackeinheiten.
Beispielsweise BTU pro Stunde und sowas, wo man sich auch fragt, wer hat sich das überlegt.
Also, wenn ich weiß, was BTU pro Stunde ist, das ist die Energiemenge, die man braucht,
die Energiemenge, die man braucht, um ein britisches Fund, ein britisches Fund Wasser,
um ein Grad britisches Fahrenheit zu erwärmen.
BTU pro Stunde.
Alles klar.
Das ist essentielle Einheit.
Die braucht man 2023 noch.
Aber die stehen da drauf.
Zum Beispiel bei USVs wird ganz viel in BTU pro Stunde angegeben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Vielleicht, wie viel die USV selbst an Abwärme verbraucht, anstatt an die Geräte weiterzugehen.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber bei USVs wird diese Einheit ganz gerne verwendet.
BTU pro Stunde.
Das ist wirklich best of Kühlleistung berechnen.
Best of bullshit Einheiten.
Ah, obviously hier.
Na gut, wobei das ist eigentlich sogar relativ klar.
Ist gleich 4186,8 Joules durch Kilogramm mal, was ist K, Leute?
Ist das Wärme?
Nee, was ist K?
Any physics five...
Kalorien ergibt keinen Sinn an der Stelle.
Kelvin?
Ist das die Temperatur?
Ja, okay.
Sixhead-Time.
Also 1000 BTU pro Stunde sind ungefähr 293 Watt.
Alles klar.
Wisst ihr, was man aber sehr schön daran sieht, ist...
Was ich schon öfters mal irgendwelchen Leuten erklären musste,
obwohl ich jetzt nicht der Ultra-Physics-Fivehead bin,
aber immerhin, dass Watt pro Stunde keinen Sinn ergibt.
Was man hieran wieder schön sieht, weil 1000 BTU pro Stunde sind
283 Watt ohne Zeiteinheit.
Was bedeutet, dass in dieser Abkürzung Watt, also in dieser Einheit,
eigentlich ja die Zeit schon mit drinne steckt.
Das heißt, Watt pro Stunde und so macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das kommt daher, weil manche Leute irgendwie auch immer noch denken,
dass Kilowattstunde quasi so das Gleiche wie Kmh ist.
Also Kmh ist ja auch falsch ausgesprochen.
Also je nachdem, wie man sieht.
Weil die denken dann, es ist quasi Kilowattdurchstunde,
was ja gar nicht stimmt.
Es ist ja Kilowattmalstunde im Gegensatz zu Kilometerdurchstunde.
Ja, die einfachste Variante ist Joules durch Sekunde.
Dann hast du das dann recht.
Wenn man das weiß.
Ja, aber zumindest ist halt die Zeit schon mit drin.
Und deswegen macht es keinen Sinn, zu sagen Watt pro Stunde.
Watt pro Stunde wäre so was wie, wenn es so eine Steigerung gebe oder so was.
Dann vielleicht, ja.
Dass man dann quasi sagen kann, okay, der Verbrauch steigt an um 5 Watt pro Stunde oder so.
Und dann braucht er das dann einem 5, dann 10, dann 15 oder irgendwie so brauch.
Ja, dann könnte man das vielleicht so angeben.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall was anderes als Kilowattstunde.
Nee, als Durchschnitt brauchst du das nicht.
Als Durchschnitt kannst du auch einfach Kilowattstunden angeben.
Verbraucht im Durchschnitt so und so viel.
Also man, du kannst das ausrechnen dann.
Du kannst die Zeit dann einmal teilen.
Okay, ja, das macht schon Sinn.
Was auch immer.
Quickmaps zu viel, quickmaps weg.
Weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Viel zu viel Backofen und so was in BTU.
Ich weiß nicht was.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich brauchst du da bestimmt.
Bestimmt 4000 BTU pro Stunde mal mal Stunden.
Also also 4000 BTU pro Stunde mal 15 Minuten.
Dann weißt du, was du verbraucht hast.
Oder was du für eine Energiemenge brauchst.
KBTU und das Ganze und das Ganze mal Stunde noch.
Meine Güte.
Gut, was auch immer.
Bin ich jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Keine Ahnung mehr, Mann.
Gibt es irgendwas spannendes, was YouTube heute empfiehlt?
Was verdient ein Straßenreiniger aktuell eindeutig zu wenig,
weil sie reinigen ja nicht mal die Straße, sondern die Streiken.
Mehr Roboter ohne Begrenzungstraße.
Oh, das gucken wir uns an.
Da bin ich auch.
Da habe ich auch so ein Auge.
Sollten die irgendwann mal was taugen?
Mein Garten ist wirklich nicht gut geeignet für Mehrroboter.
Also der hat teilweise Wurzel und der hat einen Teich und so was.
Also sprich, das Ding muss damit klarkommen,
dass er darf nicht in Teich fallen und da absaufen.
Der darf auch nicht an Wurzeln hängen bleiben.
Und seine, seine, ja.
Und ein Messer kaputt machen und so was.
Gnome 44 wurde angekündigt, tatsächlich.
Hier, da steht es ja auch.
Moment, das können wir uns nicht angucken.
Das ist wieder der Dude, der Firefox nicht mehr verwenden will
und jetzt wieder Firefox verwendet.
Der erste wirklich intelligente Smart...
Fire TV.
Nee, nee, nee.
Amazon Fernsehen kommt mir bestimmt nicht in die Bude.
Na, der ja nicht mehr.
Der ja nicht mehr.
Die haben ja geschrieben, dass das ohne Begrenzungstraße ist.
Nee, da muss man sich ja drum kümmern.
Ohne Begrenzungstraße.
Erster Mehrroboter ohne Begrenzungstraße.
Ne, da muss man sich ja drum kümmern.
Ohne Begrenzungstraße.
Erster Mehrroboter ohne Begrenzungstraße.
Was stimmt über Programmieren?
Vor dem haben wir uns schon ein paar Videos angeguckt.
Was hat er denn sonst noch?
Bevor du dualen studierst, schau dir dieses Video.
Ich will nicht dualen studieren.
Was?
87% aller Menschen scheitern ohne diese Fähigkeit beim Programmieren.
Okay, können wir uns nachhaken.
Die Videos sind immer kurz und knackig.
87% der Menschen scheitern.
Ich würde sagen, 87% der Menschen scheitern schon mal generell am Programmieren.
Wobei ich würde sogar weitergehen, dass deutlich mehr,
höherer Prozentsatz der Weltbevölkerung am Programmieren scheitert als 87%.
Okay, Fireship kann ich mir aktuell gerade gar nicht mehr geben.
Fireship ist im Prinzip nur noch AI.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Chat-GPT-Copilot.
Chat-GPT-Pilot.
Na gut, ich verstehe es ja.
Ich verstehe das ja.
Guck mal hier.
GPT, GPT.
Ich verstehe es ja.
Der Kram kriegt halt einfach mega krass Views.
Ich verstehe es aber insofern nicht so ganz, weil...
Okay.
Ich finde diese ganzen AI-Videos schon seit Monaten langweilig.
Da ist mal das eine oder andere Interessante dabei.
Aber zum größten Teil ist es einfach nur langweilig,
weil es immer das Gleiche ist.
Ja, Fireship macht die Videos gut, das stimmt schon.
Aber ich kann langsam wirklich keine AI-Videos mehr gucken.
Es ist immer das Gleiche, ja.
Chat-GPT wird irgendwas gefragt.
Die Leute sind immer furchtbar beeindruckt.
Die Videos sind halt so gemacht, dass sie eben genau die Sachen so fragen,
dass eben besonders coole Ergebnisse rauskommt.
Wahrscheinlich sogar 3-4 Mal noch aufgenommen.
Klar, ich sage doch gar nichts dagegen, dass das nicht cool ist.
Aber irgendwann ist auch mal gut.
Ich brauche nicht das 20. Video, wo Chat-GPT
irgendeine billige App oder eine Webseite oder sonst was erstellt.
Es sollten viel lieber die Leute mal Videos drüber machen.
Da gibt es recht wenige.
Ob und wie sie Chat-GPT und AI im Alltag verwenden,
das finde ich nämlich viel interessanter.
Zum Beispiel zu sagen,
man könnte Chat-Messages damit generieren,
wenn man keinen Bock hat, dem Typ zu antworten
oder E-Mail-Antworten generieren,
wenn man darauf keinen Bock mehr hat.
Da gab es von einer CT ein Video dazu.
Das ist dann teilweise schon auch ganz interessant.
Aber so dieses X.
Chat-GPT macht meine Webseite,
Chat-GPT macht mich überflüssig, blablabla.
Das ist irgendwann auch mal gut.
Dann gibt es sicherlich auch wieder irgendwelche Videos.
Rate ich jetzt, weiß ich nicht, aber kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Wieder Chat-GPT ersetzt mich einen Tag am Arbeitsplatz,
ob es die Leute merken, so nach dem Motto Videos.
Das wird dann so aufgebaut, so nach dem Motto
merken es die Leute, nein, sie merken es nicht,
obwohl das eben vorfällt.
Ich habe niemand gesagt, dass das so ist.
Ja, ja, ist klar, das wussten im Vorfeld alle.
Zur höflichen Mail-Generierung.
Dafür ist es gut, dafür benutze ich es auch.
Also ich benutze das, das ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch.
Ich benutze das, um auf E-Mails zu antworten
oder ich benutze das auch ganz gerne zum Beispiel,
wenn ich an die Personalabteilung bei mir
beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber schreiben muss.
Dann haue ich dann auch in Chat-GPT rein,
so nach dem Motto, frag mal, wann die endlich
mein Zeugnis fertig haben.
Und das aber in nett.
Dann sehr geehrte,
da kann man auch die Frau von der Personalabteilung
reinschreiben, sehr geehrte Frau XY,
ich melde mich bezüglich,
das blablabla,
Chat-GPT schwarf,
oder Chat-GPT schwafelt dir
eine halbe Seite voll.
Und dann hast du nett gefragt,
wann kriegen die endlich mal mein
Zeugnis fertig?
Übrigens,
ich habe gehört, mein Zeugnis ist jetzt fertig.
Tatsächlich.
Kann ich
nächste Woche abholen?
Dann brauche ich nur noch,
ich meine, die hatten jetzt,
die hatten nur 3 Monate Zeit,
das Zeugnis zu schreiben.
Da kann es schon mal ein bisschen
dauern. Das kann,
das muss erst am letzten Arbeitstag fertig werden.
Nächste Woche Mittwoch
ist mein letzter Arbeitstag hier, da.
Und
genau da
ist es fertig.
Stripes, die sind verpflichtet.
Die sind verpflichtet,
dir eins auszustellen.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Probleme hast,
dass der neue Arbeitgeber sagt, du darfst da nur
mit Zeugnis anfangen, dann kannst du die sogar verklagen.
Da müssen sie dir dann für Dienstausfall bezahlen.
Wenn dir natürlich kein
Schaden entstanden ist, ist schwierig da,
aber
also sie sind verpflichtet.
Die müssen das, sind da gesetzlich
dazu verdonnert.
Baldios,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions heute wieder.
Das kann auch,
vor allem kann das nicht sein.
Warum brauchen Arbeitgeber
länger als du noch da bist,
um den Zeugnis auszustellen?
Das ist mit einem, das ist mit einem
Zeugnisgenerator
in der Viertelstunde passiert
und danach noch ein bisschen schön machen und gut ist.
Die können sogar Chat-GPT fragen.
Das weiß ich gar nicht,
ich glaube nicht.
Man hat, man hat,
man hat
den Anspruch darauf,
dass die das bis
zum Ausscheiden aus dem Betrieb
ausgestellt haben müssen.
Die müssen das, die sind verpflichtet.
Du musst das noch nicht mal anfordern.
Die müssen dir das ausstellen von sich aus.
Vielleicht
verjährt das irgendwann, ja okay.
Aber
spätestens, wenn du nachgefragt hast
und sie es nicht hingekriegt haben.
Du hast einen Zeugnisgenerator
für zwei Firmen, Moment.
Es gibt wirklich welche, die kaufen sich so was
noch mit Eigenentwicklung?
Ich mein, so was gibt es doch schon zu
hundert, tausendfach.
Naja, dafür gibt es
der Zeugnisgenerator.
Die schreiben der Personalabteilung fix und fertig
so ein Zeugnis, du schreibst da Stichworte rein
und das macht dann in
ZeugnisSpeak das raus.
Im Zweifelsfall kannst du sogar
Chat-GPT mittlerweile fragen,
die wahrscheinlich noch ganz gute
Arbeitszeugnisse erstellen kann, das würde mich nicht wundern.
Ich glaube für sowas ist Chat-GPT wirklich
ganz nice.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, die Personalabteilung
macht es absichtlich nicht in Chat-GPT,
weil sie dann vielleicht feststellen wie useless
manche, nicht alle,
es gibt ja durchaus
fähige Leute in der Personalabteilung,
da war ich auch sehr überrascht
von dort, wo
ich mich jetzt beworben habe,
dass die Personalabteilung dort sogar
Ahnung hat von dem, was sie macht
und hilfreich ist
und irgendwie denen, soll ich sagen,
einen kompetenten Eindruck vermittelt.
Das bin ich von meiner aktuellen Personalabteilung
gar nicht gewohnt gewesen.
Ja,
die haben sogar, muss man, müsst ihr mal vorstellen,
die haben sogar eine Hotline
bis 18 Uhr bei der
Personalabteilung, wo man anrufen kann, wenn man Fragen
hat zu seiner Abrechnung, zu irgendwelchen
internen Abläufen und sonst was, kann man
bis 18 Uhr bei einer Hotline
von der Personalabteilung anrufen,
wo dann immer einer besetzt ist,
wo dann immer einer da ist, das habe ich so auch noch nie irgendwo erlebt.
Mitten in der Nacht, ja, bis 18 Uhr.
Was ist das?
Ja, das kriegen die sicherlich gut bezahlt.
Ich muss ja dann auch die ein oder andere Telefon
Erreichbarkeit haben,
das kriege ich auch
äußerst gut vergütet.
Kann man echt nichts sagen, also bezahlungstechnisch
ist in dem neuen Laden wirklich Ast rein.
Wenn allerdings das
mit der Inflationsrate so weitergeht,
dann ist das, wenn sich da die nächsten Jahre dann
nichts tut, bald normal.
Also, vorausgesetzt bei den anderen
geht ordentlich was.
Es muss ja theoretisch,
dass es gleich bleibt, im Jahr
fast 10%, das wird im Leben bei
vielen Jobs nicht passieren, ja.
Es müsste ja fast im Jahr 10% mehr
Geld geben.
Dass das, dass das
sich aktuell
halbwegs plus minus null
ausgeht, das werden die wenigsten
machen. Aber
kein Wunder, das wird die nächsten
Jahre noch witzig werden.
Wir werden sicherlich noch deutlich mehr
solche Streikse wie jetzt
erleben, sei es Bahn, sei es Post,
sei es Müllabfuhr und sonst was.
Eventuell auch keine Ahnung.
Wobei Lehrer, die sind Beamte, die dürfen gar nicht.
Nee, das
ist eher nicht realistisch.
Realistisch ist alles, was du dich mit denen drauf einigen kannst.
Dass ich da jemand
zu automatischen 10%
in den Gehaltserhöhungen im Jahr verpflichtet.
Das
glaube ich nicht.
Schau dir doch Amazon an mit den, hä? Verstehe ich nicht.
Was? Wie?
Ja,
mal gucken.
Das heißt auch,
wenn das jetzt weiter so bleibt,
dann muss das, muss das weiter
Big Stonks mäßig steigen.
Sonst, sonst wird das nichts.
Wo ist eigentlich jetzt mal eine ganz blöde
Frage nebenbei, ja?
Ich bin ja nicht so der,
der BWL-Kennner.
Aber mal eine ganz, mal eine ganz blöde, blöde Frage.
Haben wir nicht eigentlich
eine ganz blöde Frage?
Haben wir nicht eigentlich eine europäische Zentralbank?
Wo ist die?
Was macht die eigentlich gerade?
Ist die nicht dafür da?
Die haben doch damals auch bei Griechenland
und so, so riesen Aktionen gemacht,
so nach dem Motto,
Griechenland, zu viel
Schulden, zu viel Inflation und alles
und haben da irgendwie die, irgendwie so die Bankenaufsicht
hingeschickt und alles Mögliche.
Man hört erstaunlich wenig
von denen gerade, oder? Was machen die denn so?
Sind die nicht eigentlich genau dafür da,
dass die Inflation nicht durch die Decke geht?
Und wenn ja, was machen die denn gerade?
Die drucken fleißig Geld.
Ist das nicht genau das Gegenteil?
Was?
Hast du gesehen,
dass Linus Tech Tips Channels gehackt wurden?
Was? Er auch?
Na gut.
Das kann ich sogar nachvollziehen.
Bei ihm haben ja mehrere Leute Zugriff drauf.
Und wenn dann einer sein PC nicht richtig
sichert, ist
Gatchirol in den Account direkt.
Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe ist,
warum YouTube es nicht schafft. Guck mal,
es wurden so viele. Der M-Core, es war einer der ersten,
den ich kenn, den es da
getroffen hat. Was ich nicht verstehe ist,
warum YouTube nicht dagegen
was macht.
Nee, ich klick nicht irgendwelche
Random Domains an.
Also,
der M-Core war einer der ersten.
Das haben sie ja bei mir auch probiert.
Das ist garantiert so einer der Mails,
die ich auch bekommen habe. Wo dann
irgendwelche .NET Programme
in .NET Programme drin sind.
Zumindest,
ich finde es merkwürdig, dass
YouTube nicht was dagegen macht.
Ich meine, es ist nicht so,
dass YouTube nicht
was dagegen macht.
Ich meine, es ist auf den ersten Blick
erstmal vielleicht schwierig,
dagegen was zu machen,
weil, muss man ja sagen,
wenn der Rechner übernommen wurde
und der Rechner quasi ferngesteuert wird,
dann bleibt die IP gleich,
die Session-Cookies gleich und alles.
Wenn das allerdings
die gleichen Session-Cookies sind,
die geklaut werden
und von einer anderen
Absender-IP kommen,
dann könnte man einfach mal
eine neue Passworteingabe fordern.
Oder alternativ
müsste man insgesamt
oder müsste
insgesamt restriktiver sein.
Aber zumindest müsste
YouTube sich dem Problem annehmen.
Also müsste
öfters Authentifizierung fordern.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was man da noch
gut,
was man da wirklich gut dagegen machen kann.
Ich meine, Rechner fernsteuern
hast du natürlich verloren.
Wenn du wirklich dir irgendeinen Trojaner eingefangen hast
und jemand kann deinen Rechner fernsteuern,
dass du quasi direkt den gleichen Browser benutzen kannst,
wo du eingeloggt bist, gut, dann ist es ja für
den Service dahinter nicht mehr zu unterscheiden,
ob der rechtmäßige Owner jetzt klickt
oder ob das
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
überferngesteuert ist.
Wenn die Session-Cookies abgegriffen werden
und das Ding auf einmal mit den gleichen Session-Cookies
von der anderen IP kommt,
dann muss man Gedanken machen, klar,
dann hast du auch wieder Probleme,
wenn du mobilfunktechnisch vielleicht
unterwegs bist, was auch immer, das ist egal,
das könnte man mit der App irgendwie noch
anders handhaben.
Ja, genau.
Und spätestens, und spätestens ohne Scheiß,
spätestens bei sowas, bei...
Ja, das ist, das muss, gut,
du könntest ja ein Opt-out machen.
Du könntest ja ein Opt-out machen, wenn die Leute
das wirklich machen wollen, machen Opt-out
und Opt-in, ich würde es auf jeden Fall aktivieren
und ich glaube, jeder größere Channel-Besitzer
würde es auf jeden Fall
auf jeden Fall
aktivieren.
Und zwar, dass du zumindest mal...
Nee, das ist überhaupt nicht,
das andere IP ist überhaupt nicht problematisch.
Wann ändert sich denn mal deine IP
daheim am DSL-Anschluss?
Einmal am Tag am DSL-Anschluss,
bei Kabel und bei anderen viel selten, das ist doch vollkommen
in Ordnung.
So, und ich würde
auf jeden Fall, jeder größere Channel-Besitzer
würde wahrscheinlich, würde wahrscheinlich
Opt-in dafür machen, dass zumindest
mal Abfragen kommen,
sobald du in die Settings-Reihen gehst.
Quasi anklicken der
Channel-Settings, einmal
bitte Passwort und Zwei-Faktor-
Authentifizierung. Du gehst so gut
wie nie in die Channel-Settings rein,
also in die richtigen Channel-Settings, nicht in den YouTube
Video-Editor in die Channel-Settings.
Genau, genau, richtig,
das ist eigentlich, genau das,
genau so denke ich mir das auch.
Bei GitHub musst du nämlich auch beim Lösch
eines Repos SMS-Pin
oder SMS-Bestätigung
angeben oder App-Code
eingeben, sowas.
Genau das könnten die auch machen und ich verstehe nicht,
warum YouTube das seit über zwei Jahren,
ich meine das hat vor zwei Jahren oder so angefangen,
nicht auf die Reihe
bekommt. Wie kann das
eigentlich sein?
Wie kann man da YouTube,
beziehungsweise Google,
da noch trauen, Security-Technisch
was auf die Reihe zu kriegen? Das
sollte doch für YouTube, oder besser
gesagt für Google sollte das doch überhaupt kein
großartiges Problem sein.
Zumindest wenn man in die
Channel-Settings reingeht,
von einer bisher nicht bekannten IP, das zumindest
dann, könnte man nochmal nachfragen.
Eventuell bringt
das ihnen nichts, das bringt ihnen sehr viel.
Was meint ihr denn, kommt das gut an?
Wenn die großen
Aushänge, Schilder, Channels, einer
nach dem anderen, jeden Monat
mal eins, zwei große Channels
übernommen werden von irgendwelchen Krypto-
Scamern?
Also sie sollten da großes Interesse dran haben.
Ist es nicht sogar so, dass bei
einigen Vodafone-Anschlüssen das mehrfach an sich
selber IP haben? Doch, doch, das ist so.
DSLine. Aber selbst dann,
dass sie die gleiche
Absende IP haben, das wäre dann umgedreht.
Dass dann mehrere Leute die gleiche IP haben
und nicht IP wechseln. Ja, das
kann schon passieren, aber dann müsste der Scammer
einen Vodafone-Anschluss haben, der zufälligerweise
beim gleichen Endpunkt rauskommt. Das ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich. Außerdem würde ich generell sagen,
beim
Betreten der Channel-Settings,
also der richtigen Channel-Settings,
einfach nochmal zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen
fordern und gut ist. Und das
alle Viertelstunde.
Reicht doch, du musst ja da nie was machen normalerweise
drin. Das juckt
die einfach nicht. Das juckt die bestimmt.
Das juckt die bestimmt.
Guck mal, das sind Riesen-Channels, die da teilweise
übernommen werden und Krypto-Scams.
Also die Erklärung,
dass es sie nicht juckt und sie
deswegen nichts dagegen machen, das glaube
ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu simpel.
YouTube ist wahrscheinlich nicht in der Lage,
sich
was auszudenken,
was sich gut in ihre Infrastruktur
integrieren lässt, mit vertretbarem
Aufwand und
man hört es ja immer öfters, dass Google
mittlerweile ein so großer
komplexer Laden ist,
dass sie sich gegenseitig
behindern und dass neue Features
teilweise Wochen, Monate,
Jahre brauchen, wenn sie überhaupt kommen
und
dass durch so viele
Stufen durch muss, dass die alles andere als agil
sind.
Ne, genau.
Jeder Channel nennt sich zufälligerweise
was mit Tesla und Elon Musk.
Mach ich auch immer.
Ich gehe als
ich gehe als
einfach in Tesluen Elon Musk
Krypto um.
Und das ganz legit
ich wollte schon immer, dass mein Channel
Tesla Elon Musk Krypto heißt.
Leute,
es wird mal wieder Zeit für ein neues Video.
oder?
Es wird langsam wirklich ernst,
was denn neuen Job angeht.
Ach so, ja tatsächlich.
Dritter, Vierter.
Ich bin wirklich aufgeregt schon so ein bisschen, wie das ist.
Ich freue mich aber auch
drauf, dass ich den aktuellen
Laden jetzt los bin und neue
Sachen.
Ja.
Ja ja, das ist bescheuert, dass
Vinos das nicht mehr anzeigt.
Hab ich es eigentlich schon eingestellt?
Guck mal, ich hab eingestellt, dass der bekannte
Dateiendung anzeigt.
Das ist auch bescheuert. Man muss sagen, diesen
Scam mit Dateiendung
gibt es seit 20 Jahren.
Dass es immer noch geht, ist lächerlich.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
warum die den Default nicht umstellen.
Vielleicht, weil dann die Oma verwirrt
ist, wenn die in ihre Dokumente
oder in ihre Downloads reinguckt und sagt
Warum heißen die Dateien auf einmal alle
I-X-E
und J-PL
und
I-S-O und was ist denn da los
und J-P-G
In dem Video geht es um was anderes.
Hups, das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht anklinken.
Okay.
Da gucken wir uns das jetzt an, weil der Chat
das empfohlen hat. Wenn der Chat das empfiehlt
muss das Pfeifen. Leute, ich hab ein Problem.
Wo ist meine Playlist mit dem
Ah, hier war die Playlist an.
Es ist
zu viel. Ich hab zu viel.
Zu viel, zu viel
Tabs offen. Moment.
Also da gucken wir uns
tatsächlich an.
This insane virus
Okay, insane.
Auf geht's.
Nee, das ist kein Word-Document.
Das ist ein Screensaver,
der ein Bild hat
von einem Word-Document. Ich muss mir das Video gar nicht
angucken, weil es schon um was geht.
Das hat
ein Custom-Icon, was aussieht wie ein
Word-Document, aber es ist ein Screensaver.
Okay, ja, ja.
Ich denke, dass ich
Know of what's going on, aber okay.
Alles klar, dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Okay, das ist
tatsächlich wieder
irgendein Windows-Scheiß.
Okay, das ist
tatsächlich wieder irgendein Windows-Scheiß.
Ja, aber mal trotzdem.
Allein schon,
wenn da Doc
Doc
Wenn da blub blub blub
.exe.doc steht, dann würde ich
mir auch Gedanken machen, auch wenn es in der falschen
Reihenfolge ist, aber irgendwas ist
das das dran.
Ah, Fifehead.
Ja, gut, da hätte ich, wenn ich ein bisschen
drüber nachgedacht hätte, hätte ich da wahrscheinlich
auch drauf kommen können.
Ja, das macht ja durchaus Sinn.
Ja, das ist in Dateinamen erlaubt, das ist halt wieder
was heißt erlaubt.
Es ist nicht explizit erlaubt,
es ist halt nicht verboten in Dateinamen.
Es ist halt einfach jedes Unicode-Zeichen
beziehungsweise jedes
ja, wie auch immer,
intern Windows-Unicode
repräsentiert, UTF-8,
um Zeichen erlaubt,
warum das nicht auf darstellbare
ASCII-Zeichen limitiert ist, näher, weil
die China-Chinesen beispielsweise auch, oder die
Russen beispielsweise auch
Windows verwenden.
Aber man könnte, aber man könnte es wahrscheinlich
explizit
verbieten im Dateinamen, dann müsste
man sich allerdings hinsetzen und Schritt halten
mit dem Unicode-Standard
beim Einführen solcher
Zeichen, aber das könnte man ja von Microsoft
eigentlich erwarten, dass sie das hinbekommen.
Leute, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat
Schwangere Frau Emoji
ist out, ich wollt grad sagen
Schwangerer Mann Emoji
ist the way to go heutzutage.
Und wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt,
das gibt es wirklich
ähm,
das gibt es wirklich.
Das wurde eingeführt, glaube ich,
mit dem vorletzten,
mit dem letzten Emoji,
mit dem vorletzten, mit dem letzten
oder dem vorletzten
Unicode-Update.
Aber es unterstützen nicht alle.
Es unterstützen nicht alle.
Also es gibt durchaus
Emoji-Fonds,
die es noch nicht
können, aber die meisten
können es mittlerweile.
Ehrlich gesagt,
warum
hätten sie den Bauch
noch ein bisschen nach oben gemacht,
dann hätte man es eigentlich auf
Fatman oder sowas nicht können.
Man könnte diese
Charakter wirklich verbieten
im Dateinamen.
Das ist eigentlich kein Ding.
Weil selbst sagen wir die Araber oder so,
die ansonsten von rechts nach links schreiben,
das könntest du anhand des Language Settings
vom Betriebssystem festmachen.
Das muss ja nicht wirklich anhand der Datei,
des Dateinamens festgemacht werden.
Okay, ja.
Okay, habe ich kapiert.
Leuchtet ein.
Next.
Okay, ja.
Ja, gut.
Dass es ein Custom-Icon ist,
das war ja bei vielen Scams schon so.
Ich verstehe.
Bekommt man da?
Ja, da sollte man eigentlich Smart Screen
Warnung bekommen, wenn man das ausführt.
Mal gucken, was sie dagegen machen.
Windows-Settings, Alter.
80 Euro ist tatsächlich noch günstig aktuell,
aber es ist viel zu teuer.
Das ist doppelte von dem, was er normalerweise kosten sollte.
itely DN Nana
what is this guy doing?
イ
つ
»
precious
vendame
r
u
m